want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some incredible
motivation from the one and only
dan pena enjoy
it's not for everybody there's seven and
a half billion people on the planet
and uh my my guesstimate is well there's
only about seven or eight hundred
thousand of us
on the planet that are willing to make
the the sacrifices vis-a-vis
focus commitment um and uh it's just
like a premier
athletes you know there's a lot of
people that run the hundred yard dash
but there's
very few of them that make it to the
olympics and there's even fewer that
meddle i love myself nobody
my wife god god bless you would say i
i worship the ground and don't get mad
at me sally i worship the ground dan
walks on
but my love for him is transitory for
the love he has for himself
self-esteem if you don't love yourself
you can't be a good husband a good
father a good anything
love you first and i have no problem and
i've been
that way even when i was doing bad
things also if you want to build more
confidence the sign says it can take up
to 254 days
of consecutive action to successfully
build
a habit so i've created a free program
for you where every day
for 254 days i will send you an unlisted
video to your email
absolutely free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below
but no one does know initially up front
you have to try you have to swing at the
plate you want people
with a like mind and that are better
than you smarter than you bill gates
simultaneously said one word
focus that's it
focus and uh in the in
the many years that i was 100 focused uh
and i created a lot a lot of wealth for
myself
uh i only thought about one thing and
that was it
and i'm not uh i'm not saying that it's
easy
because if it were easy there'd be like
a qla
shop on every corner like starbucks
my market is 700 000 people out of 7
billion
if you want to be me 700
000 out of 7 billion i don't know what
fraction that is
but it's not a very big one that's it
there's 700 000 people on the planet
that
can commit to the focus the laser beam
focus
of the gates trumps ellison's etc
if you if you want to if you want to
create
generational wealth generational wealth
as well that you make in 20 to 25 years
because depending on who where you
google it a generation is
20 to 25 years we we do that and i've
taught and i did it myself
uh how to do it in four to seven years
and um
the uh in virtually throwing everything
that you've learned or read
out the window but it's focus and not
that many people can stay focused
in fact that's an understatement that
gross understanding hardly anybody can
stay focused
the system that i've seen that works
which is very much contrary to all the
other
success guys which i don't consider
myself is the mentorship
where somebody mentors you so you find
somebody
that is where you want to be and has
accomplished all this either man or
woman
and then you find them uh and you come
to them with your dream
uh and your passion and and and uh
assuming the chemistry's right and it's
not always right
uh uh the rest is history it's like the
tyson gust the motto deal
you know yeah okay tyson by accident
the greatest respect mike found that guy
when he was 13 14 years old when he was
you know doing all kind of ugly things
not dissimilar to myself about
the same age uh and um and gus
mentored him and tutored him and then as
that and
you know mike will admit i guess i don't
know i've never talked about
you know when uh when gus died and all
that all that stuff happened
he made some importance he made some
very poor decisions
so you got to find that person and you
don't just
you're not just going to find them you
know walking down the street on the high
street
i mean you have to make a concerted
effort to find somebody
that that that you you look up to
and normally that person is several
years older than you
but they're successful in what you want
to do question is
do you the person asking the question
have what it takes to do what
dan did um and um
you never know um
but no one does know initially up front
you have to try you have to swing at the
plate you have to you know
take risk you have to be willing to
sacrifice
you have to be wanting to make
commitment
and just do it i keep saying that i mean
it's simplistic it sounds like i'm
you know uh
i'm not i haven't thought the question
to you but that's not the point at all
the point is
after 21 years of coaching and after
almost 45 years of doing this myself
and being a high performance person in
six decades i realize
you just gotta do it i look like you're
a group no
it doesn't look like your group i mean
no
weight shaped man or a form you know
maybe if we had a bunch of bunny rabbits
running there uh or
it's unbelievable but again you are who
you hang around with you know
and as oprah winfrey says and which i i
talk about a lot
is that you want people with a like mind
and
that are better than you smarter than
you
more intelligent than you to get on your
bus and don't be so
concerned about what you're going to do
with those people but you want to you
know
the joint brain is you know
there's nothing the joint brain
collective brain or brains
can't overcome and i give the example of
the atomic bomb the manhattan project
and they were put together and they were
told we need
we need to develop a weapon of mass
destruction which they didn't call it
that back in those days
uh in the middle 40s to end the war in
the pacific
and they did they didn't know if it was
implode or explode but they did
but if you're if your team doesn't look
like that
then you should i won't say you should
give serious thought you should just
change a kid like you if you had to keep
track
of seven days a week 24 hours a day what
you do
you would be shocked astounded
overwhelmed or as they say in britain
gobsmacked
how much time you waste
and i make them keep track of every
minute of the day
every minute of the day and uh it's not
easy
it's not easy uh and uh when you find it
out
the uh well i have people that have come
to the seminar
that spend 20 hours a day
walking in the fresh air and meditating
20 hours a week excuse me not a day 20
hours a week and they don't get anything
done
and they don't feel relaxed what what
takes you off what like what really sets
you off right now
you mean irritates me irritates you
pisses you off yeah uh
a man's greatest burden is unfulfilled
potential
man's greatest burden is unfulfilled
potential and and i say
when i look at the audiences uh and i
know that
maybe only one percent are going to
achieve their potential
not fully put i i still haven't
fulfilled my potential
but un unfulfilled potential is man's
greatest burden
and it breaks my heart because i know
what your kids are capable of
i know i've i've had kids with 80 iq to
180 iq
that i mentored that have that have done
big
big deals actually the 80 iq did better
than the 180 iq
okay and i know what they're capable of
and i i know
how 10 million or 100 million
whatever the number is changes lives
and uh the uh and then all of a sudden
you know uh you believe that you can
walk on water
you believe that you can take a loaf of
bread and feed
however mean he was supposed to have fed
and make water into uh
wine and when you believe it see the re
the the true test of a leader is when
you've trained
other people to be leaders
it's in you kids i mean you can do it if
you want it bad enough
and you stay focused and you're willing
to uh
maintain that commitment i'm 15 pounds
overweight my doctor said and he said
you know if you wanted to be in perfect
health which everything else is perfect
my health i'm
i'm well you should lose 15 pounds and i
said i'd have to give up
three or four martinis and a bottle of
wine every night i'm not willing to do
that
it's i know what it takes and i know
what i have to do
i used to run marathons i run the boston
marathon and i know what it
took to train um and i'm not you know i
don't run
like that anymore i stare master but i
mean i
we all know how to lose weight we all
know how to get physically fit
we all know how to build our businesses
i can go to the yellow pages today and
pick out any business that's in this
room
and i can find somebody that's beating
your brains out
i don't care what you do
and as some of you heard me say but i'm
going to say it again because it's
important
for this example again we all have a
hundred iq
for some of you i'm giving you some for
some i'm taking away some
we all know nobody can have 10 times our
iq well then why the hell
do people make 10 times more than we do
a thousand times more than we do
why because they think
and dream bigger than we do high
performance people
have high expectations not average
expectations
matthew and i were discussing some of
the things
about why you discounted
on a subconscious level some of the
things have happened because
absence of evidence is not evidence of
absence and
he said there's something very profound
for an australian this is heavy duty
but he said i decided to do it even
though it was i decided to do it
meaning the follow the process to an
intellectually bright guy who's an
engineer
and see you won't
you you see you'll figure out a better
way
and he followed this process that works
and has been working for
45 years 20 some years before when i was
doing it
and 22 years since i've been coaching
and he called it and
he wasn't trying to be insulting or
anything he says i just decided to
follow that you know how did you say it
instead of trying to be smart i would
just try to be stupid shut that part off
of my brain
and just do it
and what happens he did it
and that's why it's hard for
the youtubers and all the other because
you
you can't dumb you know dumb down
you won't you will not believe that it's
easy
you can't you know you won't
but he put it very succinctly
you know he just dumbed down and shut
off that part of his brain and just
followed the steps
you don't need case studies
you have a you have a template
you have a script that a monkey
can read that alex wants a
case study because he wants to know that
behind it because he's
and that's why he's been poor you don't
need any
case studies how many times do i have to
say
you had the script i said don't change a
word on the script not a comma
if it's got misspelled words send it out
misspelled
the last thing you need is a
case study
this is why you're poor this is why
you're watching this on youtube we're so
poor mr carnegie was a hard bastard
vanderbilt was a hard bastard henry ford
the first was a hard bastard
rockefeller was a hard bastard steve
jobs was a ruthless hard bastard
as apple ceo cook regularly begins
sending emails at 4 30 in the morning on
sunday
he's a hard bastard why are all these
guys
that change the world got one thing in
common they're
tough as nails ruthless
take their prisoners and then we got you
a stiff drink and a good kill most
people in this room
i'm ashamed to say in fact forget the
stiff drink just a good
my proceeds from paypal acquisition were
80 180 million
then i had to borrow money for rent
these guys myself included are all in
if they believe in what they're doing
they put all their money at risk
and which i have several times not in
recent years
a spacex worker reveals a brutal company
model
uh motto helped him survive all-nighters
working
for elon musk notorious workaholic elon
musk is so tied
to his office that he's been known to
sleep on the floor i slept on the floor
ford slept on the floor jobs slept on
the four
gates slept on the floor success
leaves clue you weenies
i still work 50 60 hours a week and i
haven't had it work in 35
years the best advice i ever got from mr
grazos do it he didn't say just
do it he didn't swear uh and the best
advice i've ever given to anybody is
just
do it uh we take too much time
procrastinating
we take two and because we're afraid of
failure in
fear is false expectations appearing
real we're worried about what other
people think
we're trying to fit in and i go through
a whole litany of
not it's not this is not true litany of
stuff
why you are where you are because you
just didn't do it
you didn't want to make a mistake you
got a mortgage you got a
two ex-wives you got a 15 year old
daughter who's uh
pregnant i can your your dad's got
alzheimer's your mother's got emphysema
spitting that blood i can go on and on
and on and on
but the bottom line is
if you had 15 years ago you had just
done it 10 years ago you just
done it five years ago if you just done
it six
months ago if you just done it you
probably wouldn't be in the position
you're in now
so i'm saying no matter what your age is
it's still time to just
go out and do it just go out and
do it this is what i'm training you to
be like the four horsemen of the
apocalypse
[ __ ] warriors not whiners not
warriors
do you think donald trump is a whiner
do you think he worries it gives up what
you think of him
do you think elon musk gives what you
think of him
do you think the late steve jobs gives
it gave what you thought of him
do you think bill gates gives up and i
go on
and on and on the only one that gives
up which is you and you and you
and the morons on youtube they said i
was [ __ ]
they stood me in the corner with a dunce
cap
but people know what a dunce cap is you
know okay
and if i turned around they put me in
the closet
kept me there four five six hours i
urinated on myself
i shut my pants until my parents came to
pick me up
now just imagine if that had happened to
you
but i used it it's not what happens to
you in life it's how you interpret what
happens
i made it make me stronger tougher
smarter
most people would just collapse when i
played football american football
the coach roy j may he rest and roast in
hell wherever he is
he says peanut you're so slow you ought
to wear the other team's jersey
do you understand what that means you're
such a poor athlete
put the other team's jersey on you know
good for us
but i kept on going hitting that line
boom
you know i'm gonna have the uh tackling
exercise one guy in the middle and
everybody just
i was that guy every day
if that had happened to you i know what
you do some of you would have committed
suicide
that it made me stronger yes i'm six
foot one 225 a twisted steel and panther
piss
at age 73
but i endured all this stuff the rumor
is that
i'm following in the footsteps of two of
my mentors
and for those of you that aren't bright
enough to know that that's lenin and
stalin
and me there's some truth to that
because i believe
in the old russian way i'm not
interested in your [ __ ] opinions
that's the last thing i need is your
opinion because if your opinion was so
[ __ ] good
you wouldn't be here
and if you look at my whole wall of
influencers they're both on there
amongst some other people like the devil
and a few others hitler
most of you have not attained material
wealth
because you've stayed in your comfort
zone every family has
a aunt an uncle a grandfather that went
out
lost a family fortune right uncle harry
crazy harry he lost
twenty thousand fifty thousand a million
whatever the number is
well that resonates in you in your brain
your little p brain
and then you hear another one your
roommate in college
he's got an uncle harry so pretty soon
the only input that you have is people
losing their family fortune
that affects you i.e
you then live within your comfort zone
i.e you don't take risks a tortoise a
turtle can only move forward
when it sticks its head and its feet out
and when it sticks its head and its feet
out its most vulnerable right
biggest risk most of you have lived a
bubble wrap life
most of you have been risk-averse
risk-averse to the extent there are
people
beyond my comprehension that get all the
way through high school
would never been screamed at never been
slapped
never been in a fight never been
reprimanded by their parents
and then look at them snowflakes
snowflakes meaning they melt under
pressure and when i say the world is
through
look at you
the reason why the aliens haven't come
down and taking us over what the
why
why are they going to learn anything no
right now
on november 8th i announced that uh
when mr trump whether you'll love him or
hate him
this was the beginning of the greatest
transformation
of wealth the world has ever seen
since world war ii now what are you what
are you going to tell your kids and your
grandkids
25 years from now when they say gee
daddy gee grandpa
what were you doing other than having
your thumb up your
ass during the greatest transformation
of wealth in the history of the world
what were you doing
nothing that's what most of you will
tell them
your grandchildren and your children
it's never going to get any better than
this kids
this is the eyes i said on youtube the
eye of the perfect
storm this is it i never thought i'd
live to see it again
this is going to make the 80s look like
a nursery rhyme
which i praise allah praise buddha
praise god
i participated in slashing and raping
everybody in the 80s
legally this is going to make that look
like a
nursery rhyme and what are you going to
tell your kids
oh i had a spreadsheet i had to think
about i had to read another book on mna
my dad was a workaholic he was a cop but
he was a workaholic
when he retired from the lapd after 28
years
he had 700 plus
days they wrote him a check for he never
took a day off
728 years he never took a day off he was
always at work
uh and the so i saw that
and i saw you know and uh although then
he went on he went with the cia and he
became a college professor
but i saw him work hard and the uh
and i aspired to follow my day and my
dad's footsteps
as far as that was concerned i turned 16
which is when you
you can get a permit to work illegally
and i got a job as a box boy
which they don't have anymore where you
put groceries in the ladies bags and you
help them out to the car
uh the first month that i worked was
august 1961 when i turned 16.
so i'm my birthday's the 10th so i
worked 20 days 21 days
my paycheck for that because i just
happened to look it up uh was 241 bucks
so i worked about 240 hours in 20 days
you you got a headache you don't want to
work i'll take your shift you you want
to go to
uh uh to the beach i'll take your shift
okay
so my first month that first 20 days at
work i was averaging 10 12 hours a day
when i'm 16 years old
i realized uh as elon musk recently said
if you work 80 hours a week and another
guy works only 40 hours a week
unless you're something's wrong with you
you're going to get twice as much done
i discovered that prayer is great
contemplation is great
but if you don't take action action
action
all the rest is wasted
and what the kids today have trouble
with they cannot reading a book
to taking action all and i'm not saying
you shouldn't read because i've read the
classics i've read shakespeare and you
know all that stuff
but it's not taking action taking action
is pulling the trigger going out and
making something happen
and even if you fail the first method
for estimating the intelligence of a
ruler is to look
at the man he surrounds himself with now
if i were going to judge you
or you or you by the guys you
hang with the guys you chill with
i think you're a [ __ ]
you hang and you bill gates does not
chill
he does not go to the super bowl
steve jobs didn't hang
why do you
you hang out with monkeys a lot of
resemblance here
you know you become a circus show me
your friends and i'll show you your
future
most of you would be embarrassed to tell
me who your
five closest buddies are i didn't know i
had this in common with the founder of
amazon but he's in the regret
minimization business
he is modeled his life styled
what will i regret when i'm 80. now that
he's 50 50-something he says now it's
going to be 90. same as me
but i've had 80 for a long long time
and there's still some things this i
have three regrets
one i'm a combat trained uh army officer
they never saw combat
two um that um
the day before my mother died at here at
the castle i'm screaming out god damn it
don't be a [ __ ] you're not sick you're
not gonna die
next morning she's dead can't go back on
that can you
and the third is i didn't set my goals
high enough
nothing about missing my son or my
daughter's sweet 16
or missing a soccer or a baseball game
no none of that
that you have been led to believe
wrongfully are important
i am a world-class eulogy griever
and every single person i've buried i
normally go to see them but
normally they ask me before they die i
go and i said well what do you
you know what do you want me to say
and they always say oh i'm sorry for it
i didn't take this risk
i didn't do this i didn't do that not
that i missed my son's wedding
not that i miss my third grandchild's
birth
all that sloppy sloppy
it's the risk they didn't take what are
you going to tell your children
what are you going to tell your
grandchildren 20 years from now
daddy grandpa what were you doing during
the greatest transformation of wealth
and the history of the
planet other than having your thumb up
your ass
what are you going to tell them oh
i was thinking about it i was
spreadsheeting it
i'm proud to say i haven't done a
spreadsheet in 10 15 years
go read another book
go listen to another read a blog listen
to a podcast
there's a hip-hop motivational guy a
black guy
um yeah and he says if if you don't want
to be successful as much as you want
lung
breath in your lungs
now you qualify in this room hardly
anybody that comes to the seminar
quantifies
when i was doing this and when i
invented qla
and didn't know it was qla at the time i
only knew it was qla when i looked back
and i put it together the uh model if
you will or the formula
i wanted it more than air
i sacrificed my god my country
my family my children my parents
my friends and guess what
it happened i am mostly titanium and
steel
parts this is me artificial shoulders
artificial collarbone
artificial knees full knees artificial
hip
i've been busted up over the years
because i do a lot of extraordinary
things
not the least of which getting run over
by a buffalo 25 years ago
but i'm always pressing the envelope
physically
and mentally and financially
i.e we started the boxing ring which uh
as i told some of you in the beginning
95 percent of everybody thought it was a
great idea 5
said that i was inhumane like the
gladiators and the lions and all kind of
and i continue to press myself
now this is a 2014 we're in new zealand
and i'm i i see a poster about um bungee
jumping and i said sally i got to do
that and sally says turn around
and it's right here this is where the
bungee jump so i got to do that
so the next morning
i'm in line there's about 50 60
millennials kind of like you guys
and they're all saying the winds were
gusting 40 to 60 miles an hour
and you can't jump so all the
millennials will go when that
wind dies down i'm going to jump that
i'm going to jump
they're all dancing around so i wait
about 10 minutes
i take 100 bill i walk up to the head of
the line
i said don't you think that the winds
died down now
he said i believe it is has sir i jump
okay i come back these guys are still
saying went out
well did you drop i didn't know the wind
died down
but when it dies down the next time i'm
gonna jump down
i believe with all my heart some of
those guys are still in line waiting
you only have one time to make a first
impression the first impression is how
you look
now i already know how i look and you
know how i look as well
second impression is when you open your
mouth
most of you with the greatest respect uh
can't speak
properly you stutter
you mumble you sweat i've learned to
like the hot lights because i want to
convey my message
so you go where there are people that
you want to be like
you find somebody that is in my whole
basis is mentorship
find somebody that is where you want to
be 20 or 30 years from now
and go to him or her now
uh and um i had the the presence of mind
to
be attracted to some very very famous
very well wealthy people
in my 50-year career and i went after
them to
not not for money not for anything like
that but i just wanted them to talk to
me and to share their wisdom
eagles fly alone i have no friends
friends are problems friends are
challenges
if you can if you aren't into yourself
and that means something else now than
what i mean
if you're not into yourself enough that
you can't spend the weekend by yourself
then you're something's wrong with you
vis-a-vis
self-esteem being a high-performance
person and accomplishing high
performance
acts something's wrong with you from a
guy i was a barrio bad boy
in the body of east los angeles to
the guthrie that's a big leap
that's a big big it doesn't
i can't imagine well came close last
year i was uh
honored by the queen of england i am
now as they call a member of st john
a member of st john which is just
thank you thank you and it's
it it's a derivative of the templar the
people that supposedly took christ's
body and you know the knights of the
templar that's what it's a derivative
of but for a kid in east l.a
who almost killed his teacher now was i
thinking about killing the teacher no
i was up on the you'd call the second
floor with an aquarium and i looked down
at the teacher
and the teacher had pissed me off and
back in those days i wasn't the kind of
guy you'd want to piss off
so i dropped the aquarium and weighed 45
pounds
by the grace of god allah buddha he
moved
and it didn't hit him in the head and
hit him in the shoulder and crushed his
shoulder right
clavicle if that had killed him back in
the mid 50s
i wouldn't be sitting here the queen
wouldn't give me anything not even a
postage stamp
and i wouldn't be living in a castle
because i would have spent the majority
of my adult life in prison
i want to open uh hundreds of salons
around the united states even in europe
my problem is how do i find a team i can
trust how do i find a good team and
that's what i'm having a lot of time
you don't find a team by not taking
action you're going to make a lot of
mistakes that's
just the way it is the more you question
it the the less you're going to be
inclined to pull the trigger
i would rather make a mistake
than just think about making a mistake
see you're so afraid
you're you're so used to playing not to
to win and playing not to lose don't
worry about it
just like the astronauts the astronauts
train for years and years and years
before they go up
for every contingency for every single
possibility
and some of the possibilities are one in
a trillion but they still train for them
practice practice practice the people
that are doing the most and
and josh alluded to it himself he
practices
it's very easy to get sloppy after
you've done a bunch of deals
i practice between one and one and a
half hours for this seminar
for every app before the seminar
so i i had in about 70 80 hours
in the seminars 50 hours long 78 75 80
hours
that i practice and i i know what's on
slide 11 58
and then you know sometimes i skip 20 30
slides and i i did skip because we had
already gone over this stuff
last night when i was working um and the
uh
because we're gonna talk about goals now
and uh and
if you don't see your vision uh
bill gates i'm told although i never
asked him he saw
a computer in every house okay
and i told you yesterday he now wishes
he said he put two computers in every
house
and most houses do have two right some
have three four five
uh and then he said i should have said a
computer said on named
in in the entire planet
but they all practice there's a slide
coming up
showing hitler practice practicing when
he was practicing
before he became chancellor in 1933 i
think it was
number 32 uh he had over a million
pictures taken of him a million
in the right pose to write this the
right hand gesture
gesture the right so he could be more
effective he studied great speakers
before him
and arguably uh mr hitler even though
he was an uh he was one of the great
orators of all time
a number of you started a business at
one time in your life
the first fifty thousand or hundred
thousand euros
in revenue when you start is geometric
growth
so everybody that has ever started a
business generated any
income that's geometric growth because
it's starting from
ground zero to the first fifty hundred
everybody with me
okay what happens
you stop playing to win and you start
playing not to lose
if when not if but when you decide that
you really want to invoke permanent
change
you start playing to win all the time
and nobody preaches that they say keep
six months of reserve in your uh
uh bank account right in case you lose
your job that's that's a common
for the first 30 years of my life i i
spent 125
of every penny that i made every year
i was always as you would say in depth
instead of debt i don't know why i call
it debt but any in-depth
why because i didn't want any backup i
didn't want any plan b
i either succeeded or died financially
qla works for
not just money this kid came to me two
years ago he had never finished higher
than 20th
in university archery he was on the
archery team in britain
never finished higher than 20th in any
meet he'd ever attended
this is him finishing first in great
britain
a year and a half later first the little
skinny wimp
he couldn't even pull the thing back i
didn't realize you know they got 60
pound bows
so he goes and get 140 pound bow well he
doesn't weigh 140 pounds
finish first
he was firing 50 to 100 arrows i said
you fire 500 arrows a day
for the next year and you'll win his
little arms
would quiver couldn't get the [ __ ]
thing back blisters cut through his
hands
but he's the champ now your goal has got
to be high standards
i talked to a couple of the kids and
financial planning kids here
and i happen to know a lot about
financial planning being one of the
forerunners 50 years ago and most of the
kids that go into that
wealth management as it's called now
don't set their standards high enough
you don't want to manage money for
people that have two or five or 10
million
you want to manage money for people that
have a hundred five hundred and a
billion
but they don't teach you that during the
training programs that merrill lynch
goldman sachs et
et cetera because they realize that only
one in a hundred is going to attain that
goal
and they want a hundred of you with five
million in your book
not one of you with a billion in your
book i drove by a college today and
i yelled boo 35 people went to the
hospital
734 needed crisis counseling 429 needed
a safe
area or room and uh classes were
canceled
for a week there are universities that
i've spoken at
that have safe floors the third floor in
the physics building
in krakow university has a safe floor
if life gets too tough for them they go
to that floor to chill
air force academy has safe cards
when they're when yeah we have a naval
academy guys so he said
that they pull when they're being beat
up too much
enlisted men going through boot camp
have safe cards
that they pull we're lucky we don't go
to war with russia they'll eat our lunch
they're going to eat us alive we're
lucky
there are no safe cards in life
i tell the kids all the time if we were
at war we'd all be dead
see you're used to making mistakes and
nothing happens
for the few of you in the military in
here you know mistakes and cost lives
my our kids are millennials but they're
not i mean you'd think that they were
godzilla attila the han and genghis khan
compared to the other millennials
our daughter is me with a skirt
she's a rough
[Music]
she's a rough girl daddy why do you want
to go
if she were standing here she'd say my
daddy treats everybody the same
like whether you're the pope
although i do cut the pope some slack
that's not quite accurate whether you're
you know whoever i mean i treat
everybody the same because i hold
everybody accountable
if you tell me you're going to do
something young lady if you don't do it
i'll rip your head off
your neck i'll be all over you like
like like a cheap suit and life is not a
journey it's only if you're a meathead
clubfoot [ __ ]
and for those of you i'm not trying to
if some of you are
have issues with retardation i'm not
trying to that's not what i'm talking
about
that's not what i'm talking about
it's a model you find someone as i said
yesterday after where
where he or she is where you want to be
and then you model them
you mimic them you copy them same way
you would if you want to be
a footballer same way you want to be if
you want to be
a golfer you don't copy some monkey
that can't break 100 do you socrates
plato and aristotle had this figured out
two or three thousand years ago
what happened why did we stop
these are arguably the first
mentor-mentee relationships that existed
on the planet
i'm not teaching anything new guys gals
i give credit to the man that i copied
andrew carnegie
came up with the qla model and didn't
call qla because he was
he could have been dutch really he was a
meat mean
cheap person that didn't want to spend
money so he didn't
allow equity in his transactions he only
used dep
as you would say debt so he would still
own it all and that's all i did
he was doing this 140 years ago what i
do but if you believe
if you believe in yourself
i had to go on obama again obama
i had a dream i'm running down
torrance boulevard 1983 and i had just
looked at a magazine called the rob
report which i recommend you all
subscribe to and it had uh castles on
islands and the uh
and i said i'm gonna buy a castle on an
island that was
march 83 i moved into the guthrie castle
september 184.
had no way to pay for it didn't have
my i had a pot to piss in but um
15 months later is that 15 or 17 months
anyway from march to september 1 the
next year
so i had an obama moment and i wasn't
even cracked up
i had a dream so even though i made fun
of these guys that have a dream but i've
had them myself
but if you don't have a dream guess what
it can't come true
and you're never going to exceed your
highest expectation
you will never for those of you that
want to make a million dollars you're
never going to make a million and one
and the current crop of kids thinks
they want to do good
so far with the greatest respect i
haven't seen too many put their money
where their goddamn mouth is
because you haven't made any money yet
all you've got is ideas
but that's great you got to start
someplace
now go out and create wealth
and then go out and do good with it as
my daughter
if she was sitting in the audit she's
going to be 30 in a few weeks
who's heard this stuff since she was in
her mother's tummy
she said that my generation daddy she
says
don't get the part about making the
money to have more choices
and she's right i hate to admit my
daughter knew something before i did but
she's right and she's a product of a
much better education than i had
but you've got a lot of choices the
the names musk is the most not most but
one of the most popular names right now
for all the stuff he's doing
but he made money with paypal and he did
all those things
and then because he was in a vogue he
got money from the government
the best place to get money for anything
that you want to do is the government
whether it's a national government a
municipality
or a county government because they have
a real challenge
if they don't use it they've got to give
it back and they won't get it the next
year
now when was the last government that
you knew that one wanted to give it back
and two didn't want it the next year
none
none um but choices and as
in my influence in my daughter's
infamous words
daddy if they understand that we have
more choices if we create wealth
i think that it'll resonate better with
the kids her being one of them
whoever being one of them last question
for me
it all sounds kind of simple do you
think anyone in this room could go and
make
hundreds of dollars
it is simple can everybody in this room
do it no
because everybody in this room is not
willing to make the sacrifices
i don't know how to do it four hour work
week which came up
a little earlier i don't know and i know
ferris
and if you believe the four hour work
week i've got a bridge to sell you
in new york i mean uh
one of the comments from the seminar
that just ended from the 18 20 kids
all of which were about half my age we
had a couple of old gifts in their 40s
but most of them were less than 30. uh
they commented at breakfast the last day
which was uh
saturday or sunday they said how can he
still
be so fired up running on 200 of all the
cylinders
when he's been on his feet 15 hours a
day for six seven eight days
and we've been sitting on our arses uh
and we're tired and he's not you know
why
because i and if you don't find
something that you love what you do
don't bother because if you don't have a
passion for what you do and your love
it gets old i say this stretching a
little
um it's like a significant other
that you've been around too much you
know what i mean everybody in this room
can relate to that i think
okay well if you're not passionate about
what you do in life
it gets old and then it becomes work and
as soon as it becomes work
you're finished the reason why i'm fired
up at the end of a six seven day week of
15
18 hours a day is because i'm passionate
about
pulling you sorry asses across the goal
line because that's my goal in life now
to pull as many of the sorry
individuals on the planet across the
goal line as i can before they put dirt
on me
you want to take the easy way out
because you think
life is a journey
that is life's a journey if you're a
[ __ ]
and you're [ __ ]
that's why you know that's what that's
what you've done with the life up here
to four
it's been a journey and how good is the
journey you tell me
wouldn't you have rather when the first
time you went out with somebody that you
thought you were in love with
thought is the operative word once you
have lied to have a template
oh let's follow this process instead of
because that is a journey
and all the mistakes you made and
raising the
little head for kids you got
instead of having this book
life doesn't have to be a journey it's a
journey for morons
do you think life is a journey for the
trump kids it's a
process the same process his daddy
raised him by
same for me life ain't a journey if
you're my kid
it's a goddamn process
so you tell me if you're results
orientated at
all
who's better off the journey or the
process
now this is me in my best attempt to be
a cholo
in east l.a that was taken 25 years ago
in front of where my house used to be
and if you can tell my house was from
the chain-link fence
to the brick wall wasn't very big house
was it
it was 800 square feet
when we were taking that picture in 1993
there was two drive-by shootings
within the neighborhood and my camera
guys
jumped under the car
that's where i come from this is where i
lived in 1972 on wall street
14 years later i think it was 12 years
later
i lived there i lived in little
they used to call them uh when they had
no uh
i i forget what they call but anyway a
little apartment i i had i i i lived in
a place called the bed bug uh bedford
but we called it the bed bug because
cockroaches were that big
quality we used to sit there and watch
our little tv and we'd see the
cockroaches
racing back and forth the floor six of
us in a two-bedroom apartment
and in 12 years not this similar to
president obama
i had a dream that i was going to
live in a castle on an island and 12
years later i moved in
dressed like the president of the prime
minister of your country
you only have one time to make a first
impression kids
you come in looking like some of you i
wouldn't give you toilet paper
most of you i'd be embarrassed the way
you're dressed or happy slappy bimbo
from
toronto or happy slappy guy
who goes to the little league games and
mesa arizona
then that's okay
but if you want to create some money and
money's not everything
but if you don't think money can buy
happiness you don't know where to shop
say that with an irish accent
okay if you don't think money can buy
happiness you don't know where to shop
i don't think money can buy happiness
you don't know where to shop correct
uh correct and but i mean you can get
money and then go save the world
and get money and save the forest in
brazil you make money and go save global
warming which i don't believe in
you i mean and save the uh the kids in
biafra and all that
but without money you can't save a thing
don't you understand don't the idiots on
youtube understand that
until you make some shekels i've run the
three generation the gamut in this
seminar here and they all say the exact
same thing
the daughter looks to the mother you
[ __ ] me up
the dog the mother looks to the father
you [ __ ] me up
and they all agree and where it really
gets dicey
is the second or three day second or
third days after they have a few drinks
a few pops then it gets
it can get ugly as sally would say
oogly nothing like a mother to turn on
her daughter or vice versa
nothing like it we have two bank
accounts like i said earlier a financial
bank account an emotional bank account
and where we all fail myself included
is emotionally i get afraid you know
but it's not what happens to you in life
it's how you react to what happens to
you in life but i just push
through i'm so used to success now you
know
not blowing smoke on my own i'm so used
to it now it's my fact pattern
i mean it's my nobody's interested in
the failures i've had last year
i had tried 22 different things that
failed
but i tried that were big successes so
nobody's interested in the oh i think
we'll try this and it didn't work i
think i'll try this and it didn't work
focus on a few not the many and i've
been given that advice for 25 years
and i was given that advice when i was
with the onassis people
um and uh we think we think
about too many different things uh and
we
we try to do too many things virtually
everybody almost everybody in the group
is trying to do too many things and the
um and
the most successful uh not unlike you
josh uh you focused uh
uh once you pivoted uh on one thing
until you got the ball across the goal
line until you got the deal financed
and until you get the actual money
finance and the
exchange uh contracts as it's called in
this country
the deal is not over until the fat lady
sings until it's over
and uh i see uh you gave an example
being on the one inch line
two three times and i see a lot of kids
falter at the one inch line
the either because they're working on
something else or they allow something
else to obstruct their
ultimate goal jack welsh arguably the
greatest ceo in the history of the world
who managed in uh general electric for
20 25 years
he said there is no work life uh balance
there are work
work life uh challenges and we make
decisions and we live with them
do you think elon musk has work-life
balance
no do you think steve jobs when he was
alive had work-life balance
no do you think bill gates no henry ford
no
original heineken no
so if none of those people that created
the wealth of the world had work-life
balance
why do you think you're going to have it
why because you deserve it
i don't think so you deserve what you
get in life
by working hard all you guys probably
had bicycles with trainer wheels right
on the little wheels on the side of the
bicycle when you ride it and you didn't
fall off and
then when the your parents took the
trainer wheels off what happened you
fell over on your head
and what if your mother probably maybe
your father oh poor baby poor baby and
rub your head
when i fell off my bike my dad hit me
your little weenies get up stand up stop
crying
man yeah i mean man up
and now look at me
i mean i wish love got the job done i
swear to god i do
but it doesn't
and god doesn't get the job done either
god helps those who help them himself
where's the fun part in your life i'm
having fun right now i love what i do
most of you in this audience don't like
what you do
that's why the greatest respect that's
why michael can help you
most of the people on the 87 poll did a
survey in 2016. 87 of the people on the
planet
not counting all the biafra uh uh you
know
uh ghana the kenyan kind of countries
87 of the planet hate what they do
they've checked out they're just taking
up time
waiting for retirement i'm sure some of
you in this room
can you know relate to that 87 percent
have checked out now to me
if you've checked out i mean what the
hell jesus
and you're all going to live older the
70 is the new 50 they tell me i don't i
don't even feel 50 i feel 30.
i act 30. i got more energy than
probably the whole room
and well because i i loved dragging you
sorry guys and gals across the goal line
my wife's lovely wife sally says the
reason i have arthritis in my back
is because you're getting heavy now that
i'm getting older dragging you across
the goal line
but i will kick spit slap
i will do whatever it takes and when i
say i do whatever it takes i can mean it
i will insult you your mother your
religion
i know how to get you to the top of the
podium
at the olympics not for a bronze medal
not for silver but for
gold if we're not going for gold don't
waste my time now
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls what
if you could
accomplish in the world today if you
weren't afraid
if you weren't afraid of what people
thought of you said about you
whispered about you
what could you accomplish
a lot more than you've accomplished
today a lot more
why do we care what people think why do
we care what people say
and more importantly why do we care what
people whisper
because we have no self-worth we have
next to little
self-esteem and we have no
self-confidence and how do we get that
way
yes mommy and daddy life expands and
contracts with courage
one was the last courage courage
type thing that you did in your lifetime
walk against the red light
whisper that your spouse your
significant other is
when was the last time you exhibited
some courage
some of you have to go back a long long
way some of you
never i said yesterday i cannot believe
that there are people in this audience
that have never
been spanked never had a harsh word
said to them by their parents never got
in a fight on the school grounds
i can't believe that and you wonder why
you are
the way you are now i'm not saying that
being a high performance person is
beating the [ __ ] out of everybody but it
doesn't hurt
a few months ago when we were working i
signed a deal for a tv show a few weeks
ago
and they were doing research and we
discovered that where i lived in 1972 on
27th and lexington
when i first went to wall street it's
now been torn down we used to call the
building the bedbug
probably some of you live in a bed bug
now and then 12 years later i was living
in the castle
12 years yes was a castle on my my
affirmations yes
was a castle uh on my goals yes with the
castle in my prayers yes
but i thought the castle was going to
have a moat and have all kind of neat
stuff
it doesn't have a map but it's pretty
neat place for those of you that have
looked at google because i could
continue to believe
i continue to believe so i've gone from
the barrio that's where my house used to
be
behind that chain link fence and you can
see between me and that brick wall isn't
very much space
we had a 800 square foot house i think
that's 75 square meter house
even some of you probably live in bigger
houses than that
and of course there i am with my lovely
wife uh
my 75th birthday i needed a new rolls
royce like i needed aids
so what did my wife give me for my 75th
birthday a roll just like the queen has
so when we drive by i go just like she
does
so you've got rich people right most of
you aren't
hanging not chilling with those people
are you
nope why you've got all kinds of reasons
why don't you
i didn't go to school that's what i got
to say about all those reasons
i didn't either but somehow i weaseled
my way into
people richer than that in a good way
because it was important to me to change
my life from being a barrio bad boy who
almost killed his teacher when he was 12
years old
if success was important you would have
done something about it by now
but it's not too late it's never too
late when i was growing up
contrary to what you were growing up i'm
13 years old and i'm wrestling with
lions that's me and jackie the lion
jackie the lion from the
mgm mr golden mirror that's the first
line jackie
so i'm not afraid of animals to this day
i'm wrestling my mother's over here out
of camera screaming and yelling
afraid that the lion is going to eat me
and then
fast forward 40 50 years there we are
with tigers you can see sally in the
background there
yes people get hurt on these things yes
people get killed on these things
that's why there's only three people in
that picture
and sally and i went trucking with the
lions a few years ago
because i'm continuing to push the
envelope i never want to be comfortable
doing anything
if you're in sales make 300 cold calls a
day 300
cold calls a day 300
cold calls a day correct will it still
work
no no absolutely yeah we got kids doing
it we even got some lazy dutch kids
doing it right now
just pick up the phone yeah yeah and i
mean for a for a dutch
kid 24 years old to make 20 cold calls a
day
you'd think it's a big deal
there's nobody's teaching sales in this
country that i'm aware of
that tells you to make 300 cold calls a
day
in fact there's nobody on the planet
that i'm aware of
that tells you to make 300 cold calls a
day i had a guy just do a 50 million
dollar deal
he said dan if you just told me i was 2
000 cold calls away
from my first deal i would have sent you
a check for 20 grand
and said thank you and i want to come to
the council so what can you do to build
self-confidence and self-esteem
you are who you hang around with show me
your friends and i'll show you your
future
show me your friends and i'll show you
your future the first self-esteem is
built the first seven or eight years of
life
who are you around the first seven or
eight years of life
mom maybe dad
older brother a uncle
a grandmother right what the hell do
they know about building self-esteem
they don't know anything and now show me
your friends i'll show your future
who do you go hang with who do you chill
with
and i and i and he he and i we disagree
about a few things but
bill gates doesn't hang steve jobs who i
knew
didn't chill um uh warren buffett
doesn't hang
elon musk doesn't hang and i go down the
list of people that don't
hang but very few people are happy
with what they're doing and if you want
to build self-esteem
deal with people that have high
self-esteem for those of you that
want to save the world go make a bunch
of money and then go save the world
or more recently the last four five six
years i've said
figure out a system a process a
procedure
an invention that changes a billion
lives
and you'll become you know a
multi-billionaire
i.e facebook zuckerberg this young kid
that came to me a year and a half ago
his goal his dream and his life was to
finish number one
university champion archer in britain
what's the best you've ever done 20th
in a regional meet he says to me so we
set up a program and i beat him like a
rented mule that's him receiving the
first place
a couple months ago in britain the
little skinny
he looks like a little nimrod snowflake
because he is
but he was firing six seven hundred
arrows a day
most of you couldn't fire fifty most of
you in this room have never been held
accountable for anything in your life
and look at the result focus focus i
focus on everything i mean i
focus on one thing at a time most of you
are engaged in two three four
different endeavors and you're not doing
any of them very well focus on one
and i never get into business i'm not
looking to exit
but by the way i said it yesterday for
those of you i've read some emails from
a couple of you you have a business two
years ago
and now you're doing 250 000 or 260 000
euros
in revenue that's geometric growth you
started from zero
24 months ago you're now doing 250 000
euros that's geometric growth
but now what did i say yesterday you
start playing not
to lose instead of playing to win focus
i mean and it's it's it's a single key
thing
when you're an athlete and i wasn't an
athlete by any stretch of the
imagination
but the world-class athletes i've had
the privilege of working with all the
same thing focus
if they're basketball players and i had
the pleasure of working with the lakers
back in their heyday
they wake up they go to sleep with a
basketball literally football do they go
to sleep i mean
from the time they get up to the time
they go to bed that's all they think
about is focus
i had a nurturing mother but i had a dad
that kicked
out of me beat me like a rented
mule
and if if my father was still alive and
i have
uncles and they'd say manny you're too
hard on danny
and he would say just as he looked into
the camera and said my son's successful
not because of me but in spite of me
he looked him in the eye and says how's
your program working out with your
crackhead
daughter
because when they compared me no matter
how much i did wrong
my success i don't know anything other
than dropping the ball in center field
which i have nightmares about to this
day
i've only had success and when you've
only had success all your
life i make money by accident
i don't know failure
i just don't and it's infectious
and you start not hanging or chilling
exposing and not exposing yourself in a
sexual way exposing yourself i got to be
careful about all these words
you start exposing yourself to
high-performance people
i mean and you'll forget how to be a
loser
every day i get stronger every day in
the seminar you get weaker
why do you think that is because i love
what i do and you
hate what you do there's a slide coming
up tomorrow
gallup poll in 2016 87
87.7 of the people on the world
hate their lives 87
most of you have lived your lives and
your parents lives
giving tacit approval tacit approval is
the reason why you're here today
and the people that are on youtube are
poor on youtube
but tacit approval is this this guy
tells me something and i know
and i just sit and listen and then i
walk away right
or god forbid and i hear and i happen to
nod in my head
okay now he goes to this other mutton
head over here
and he says uh uh dan's on board
not because i said i was on board
or by accident nodded my head up and
down because i didn't
say i wasn't on board in his mind i've
given him tacit approval
you've lived your whole lives for those
of you that work in big
organizations you listen to your boss
you know he's full of
would you just sit there and listen i
got in trouble i used to say you're
fully
that's all my life
and i told you dr shirley teeter said
the only thing that's changed with danny
pena
is that his accomplishments have caught
up with his big
mouth and the thing that always amuses
me
is that the current day movies and stuff
at the end of the movie normally the
people reconcile
that's not my experience
the higher performer the higher the
performance person
the less probability that they're going
to reconcile with anybody why
because they don't need anybody
and almost all the big hitters i know
and president trump
is a primary example of this a
preeminent example
saying sorry is a weakness
apologizing is a weakness saying
you were wrong was a weakness what do i
say
i may be wrong but i'm never in doubt
every i know
which flies in the face of all now
president trump doubles down triples
down
i don't know if you can quadruple down
but
and that's my experience with those guys
and the few
really high-powered women that i've
known
so again it flies in the face of
virtually everything you've been taught
some people will never like me and i
will never give a
you worry about what they say as i told
brian rose many years four years ago
you have no idea how limitless your life
becomes vis-a-vis goals
when you don't give what people think
say or whisper about you
you have no idea the world will not
value me until i value myself
and the reason why people don't value
kids is because you don't value yourself
confidence is not they will like me
confidence is
i'll be fine if they don't like me
now it's safe to say that i've never
been worried about what people think of
me
that's the truth jeff is worth about 150
billion dollars the founder of amazon
this is what he looked like almost 20
years ago
20 years ago they laughed at him
20 years ago it wasn't worth twenty
thousand dollars let alone 150 billion
now he's got to come a company roughly
speaking around a trillion dollars
a little less maybe 150 billion less
because of the
sell-off in the market et cetera but
they laughed at him he had an idea
he had a dream
like him i had a dream about 35 years
ago
i am the first person on the planet
that took an option for something he did
not own
public on a major stock exchange
i'm gonna say okay i don't own that book
right
i paid him a dollar i own an option i'll
give you five dollars for that book
a year from now i took an option
i took that book not owning it and i
sold it on the new york stock exchange
for 150 million bucks
that's what i did and that was the
beginning
of my quantum leap but there was 25
years straight from 1991 to 1996
i didn't take a day off 25 years
straight
1991 71 to 1996.
71 tonight i didn't take a day off
success is like being pregnant everyone
says congratulations but nobody knows
how many times you got
you have three million pores in your
body three million
i've been in every one of them at least
twice in a bad way
i have a young mentee in the room who
just recently
got his first um and i'm not making
light of rape and like that but but
basically recently almost got his first
financial raping here recently
um and i have a lot of scar tissue
because you know
if i allow people to disappoint me i'd
never get out of bed in the morning
i happen to be in excellent physical
condition uh not
if i'm 72. if i'm 32 i'm in an excellent
excellency
but i work at it and i have worked at it
since uh 1974
what is now called biohacking i started
being aware of my physical condition
i uh test my blood every six to eight
weeks
i've got you know i told you yesterday i
wasn't joking about my testosterone
level
um the uh but i work at it and uh but
when i turn 60 i
only drink when i'm traveling now or at
the seminar i don't drink and i'm a
vegan when i'm at home
not because i believe in that vegan
horse but it i
i lose weight like crazy when you're a
vegan when i was in poland as i said
last
yesterday afternoon i i talked about
some very successful kids and i said
john stand up he's 22 years old he's
currently a student
at krakow university he made a million
euros last year which is no big
deal to me but to most of you a million
euros is a big deal
now one single student went up to ask
him what his name was
john what because if they did
and he's told them the tip the secret
the secret sauce
they may feel some responsibility to try
to do it themselves and then when they
failed
then the you know most of the podcasts
most of the seminars most of the various
things that you study
you're not learning
otherwise why are you still here with
the greatest respect to michael
there's no reason
when you leave here today after the q a
is over
and i've already told you everything's
free on my website i don't i
and when you see me at the airport don't
come up and talk to me don't touch me
i don't give a [ __ ] if you live or die
my
obsession is to drive as many of you
lazy bastards across the goal line
as humanly possible before i die that's
it
if i have to hurt you spit on you
call your mother i don't care there was
a sliding
pile of crap five or six slides ago and
most of what you've learned
today about creating generational wealth
being an entrepreneur
starting a business is crap
[Music]
i heard somebody say earlier about a
business plan
business plans are passed
they're not needed i'll explain to you
later why they're not needed
because a business plan is just a wild
ass guess
i've never seen in 50 years of doing a
business plan
fail on paper i'm going to say that
leave the navy guys i'm going to say it
again
i've never seen a business plan fail on
paper
why because you put the most optimistic
in there right
[Music]
so who's going to believe a business
plan only morons
[Music]
that's why they're not needed if you
started a business the first 50 000
pounds
euros or dollars in your business was
geometric growth
quantum leap the next 50 or 100 000
or pounds or euros was geometric growth
then what happened
you started playing not to lose instead
of playing to win
you sat on your assets like a mother hen
and were afraid that you're going to
lose the money that you made
anybody that's gone from zero to a
hundred thousand zero to ten thousand
has created geometric growth some of you
sorry [ __ ] in this room have
which is hard to believe shows it goes
to show any person can do it
even brain dead retards like you
the first dollar that you make
euro pound is geometric growth you
retards
then why didn't you continue i know fear
works
and i'm a proponent of it
and anybody thinks any different is
crazy bullish
i don't know right the right terminology
fear still works just in athletics today
um you you uh university of
central florida who won one of the
national championships in football last
year
um the fear of not making the team
they use to recruit
because they're one of the two national
champions and the other whoever the
other one was
the fear of getting cut from the team
in athletics the fear of not making the
olympic team
the fear of uh not okay getting good
enough grades to get into harvard or
wherever the
[ __ ] you know you want to go to school
but they they they couch it differently
now they don't call it fear
they call it motivation but motivation
through fear works when josh was uh
um he had a 60 hour
a week job and he was doing qla 70 hours
a week
that doesn't give much room for sleep
does it
but you'll say well he was 17 18 you
don't need to sleep when you're 17 18.
you've already you already got a reason
why he you can't work
40 hours a week that you need sleep
he cut back to three hours a night sleep
the guy you just
listened to and then he couldn't take it
he only lasted a few weeks at three
hours a night sleeping so he had to go
back to four hours
when you know it's like when you were in
lust with that person you know
you wanted to [ __ ] all night in the
toilet in the car
in the closet when you when you figure
out that every hour you sleep you're not
making money
you'll never sleep again now money's not
everything
it's the only thing anybody keeps track
of but it's not everything but for those
of you who want to save the world
go find a product an idea that will
change a billion lives
and by by definition one you'll save the
world and two you'll be a billionaire
because you see gates and buffett and a
number of the luminaries that have made
a lot a lot of money in current day
they've made a lot of money now they're
trying to save the world
bill gates wasn't running around with a
placard as they say in this country
around the embassy about save the
rainforest
when he was 17 18 20 years old
and we have some save the world guys in
the in the audience and we have
save the world guys in every audience
you know when our children uh
finished undergraduate school and they
both worked before they went
undergraduate school i told both
kelly and derek make 300 cold calls a
day and you'll lead the nation
in sales or in anything you do 300 cold
calls a day
and that's getting through to somebody
not leaving a message
and they both did
you cannot even if you're [ __ ] like
you guys if you make 300 legitimate cold
calls
you'll make a million dollars a year no
problem
and that's not a lot of money and i i
say that uh
begrudgingly but to most people it is
that's 12 that's 1500 cold calls a week
that's 6 000 cold calls a month
that's 72 000 cold calls a year
if you can't make a millionaire you
ought to kill yourself metaphorically
speaking
be firm but fair but firm
because uh people appreciate their their
the the kids don't lack ingenuity what
they lack is
leadership and now being a firm leader
uh is considered politically incorrect
showing tough love
they forget the tough part and they only
remember the love part book do you
recommend a tough minor management
correct right
yeah it's still a very relevant book
it is and joe batten was the mentor of
ross perot a billionaire back in the day
uh and he also wrote a great book my
principles i think yeah that's
my life and my principles yeah no not
many people read it because it's not a
very popular no no and he also wrote a
book uh tough minded leadership
yeah and those are the only two books
you need on uh management and leadership
our kids were here right now my daughter
would say jesus christ the world is
dead for another reason though why
anybody would want to be raised by you
they you have no idea what it was to be
your child i'm sure i don't
i don't and my daughter i think i
mentioned yesterday my dad shoots
everybody the same like
and i'm hard and hard works
world-class coaches are hard
we have a guy in the uh hall of
fame my most successful mentees he says
i haven't been beat this hard
since i was uh the number two guy on the
austrian ski team
arguably one of the best ski teams in
the world and then he blew out his knee
and his coach used to beat him i mean
physically beat him now i can't get away
with that anymore
but uh the uh most of you needed a
beating growing up
you just did and most of you your
parents
your parents weren't weren't trained
to to produce high-performance kids
you you and i both know it you and i
both know it
we've had we've had grandfathers
daughters granddaughters
and we've had uh sons
and fathers in the seminar room and when
you ask the grandfather
i did the best we know how ask the
mother
you don't know what you don't know ask
the kid
you don't know what your kids really
think about you i do
i get their emails
most of your kids are embarrassed by you
in some cases i'm sorry to say ashamed
of you i have another idea i might i
might do
uh which i think could make maybe a
million but
am i just should i just abort everything
and just well most of you that have
businesses in the room should go home
and turn the key
does everybody understand that close
them down don't open up monday
i can say that i don't even have to look
at your numbers
turn the key adios
[Music]
something new because most of you are
living quiet lives of desperation
most of you are living hand-to-mouth
paycheck to paycheck that's a hell of an
existence
i used to be there believe me i know
what that feels like
you know and uh but if you're not in a
big margin
low-hanging fruit if you're not in the
new economy
if you're not in healthcare if you're
not in telco
if you're not in uh cyber security
if you're not in uh radiology if you're
not in the things that
building infrastructure building roads
building bridges
you just you might as well blow
metaphorically you might as well just
blow your
brains out because sally
she says god damn it dan you said
remember what the lawyers told us
so the lawyers you know the people with
the best communication skills
do best at this and most of your
communication skills suck
most of the retards i don't mean
[ __ ] in that sense
retards watching this and youtube have
no communication skills
at one time i had support communication
skills they used to throw plates at me
when i talk
go to a rotary club to give a speech can
you
they threw place at me
your feelings would be heard i tell the
kids
you're gonna hear something here that
you not here you haven't heard
growing up i want you to be more selfish
to fulfill your dreams and for those
people that are getting in the way of
your dreams
uh the uh don't be more selfish to them
just extract them from your life it's a
lot easier
and uh my first wife or my uh
current wife for many years we're here
to tell you they'd say
uh we we worship the ground dan walks on
but nobody loves dan more than dan
my love for my husband is transitory
compared to his love for himself nobody
[ __ ] loves me more than me
and that's how you be the best husband
the best student
the best father the best brother the
best grandchild
the best citizen in my judgment is love
of yourself
of course that self-esteem that
self-confidence
then you think about what other people
think say about you etc
but we really haven't dwelled on
because it's a waste of time uh how much
time you waste
worrying and of course you worry because
you have
thin skin uh um
uh adenauer the former mayor of berlin
said uh the thick skin was a gift from
god
thick skin he was a politician a very
successful politician
and uh the uh sally
calls me rhino skin um because
it takes it's true i mean i can't
remember
the last time uh that somebody said
something that uh
well i can't ever remember since i'm a
kid somebody's saying something hurt me
i mean hurt my feelings i
i just i think back about you know
and i can't i can't remember and i'm
sure everybody in this room can remember
somebody saying something about them
that hurt your feelings
i can't remember and you can remember
because uh i just you know uh
i wasn't raised that way if you want
we'll go back home it's to do what
i i don't know i want to become wealthy
well i mean it's easier to become
wealthy here than romania
although we have romanian mentees
millionaires
we do but it's harder here it's easy
well numb
it's not easy easy but lithuania
hungary romania those countries it's
harder oh the best deal in 25 years
was just done by one of my hungarian
mentees
and he just did the second best deal in
25 years on top of that deal
and he's a little uh uh
peter if you're listening i mean i mean
he didn't have enough self-confidence to
brush his own teeth i mean and now he's
a
wealthy guy on the cover of hungarian
business
and he did it without paying one bribe
and that's a big deal to know that part
of the world so but i mean
you got to follow your heart i don't
mean a lovey-gooshy way for your mom
i mean you got to follow your heart
because in 25 years from now your
mother's going to be dead
and you're going to regret that you
spend any time with her
i'm in the regret minimization business
what are you going to tell your
grandkids during the greatest
transformation of
wealth in the history of the planet what
were you doing
other than having a thumb up your ass if
you can't sell your dream
nobody's going to join you oprah
winfrey's got a saying about you know
it's it's not
exactly important where the bus is going
but the people that you have on the bus
with you
because you're going to morph you're
going to pivot which is true
and if you are not enthusiastic
overwhelmingly enthusiastic
that's not been one of my uh
shortcomings
i've always been enthusiastic and um and
i've had uh
good good the great communication skills
and the uh but you don't have if if you
if your communications goes a five
percent of mine they have no problem
being a billionaire
five percent of mine five percent and
that's why i tell you go to improm
go to toastmasters et cetera i got a f
in public speaking in high school
i got an f in public speaking in
university and i got a d in public
speaking the second time in university
but then i went and made two 250
speeches where i told you and
some of you don't believe me they threw
plates at me
they threw dinner rolls at me but i
didn't leave the podium
i emptied out auditoriums my speaking
skills were so poor but the world has
become sophisticated
political correctness reigns
and i'm here to tell you in my humble
opinion there's nothing humble about me
that political correctness is a
manifestation of lack of self-esteem
because you care about what people say
about you you care about what people
think about you
[Music]
and i don't and either there's jeff
bebos bill gates
warren buffett elon musk
henry ford the first and i go down the
list
i don't think i think people realize
that um
how great you are as a communicator and
i'm always
very uh like shocked
at how good you are even as a
storyteller how great your memory is
you'll be to tell story how do you do
that well i work at it
when i first started i didn't have any
stories yes i only had the stories of my
mentors
yeah okay uh and so jim nielman yeah
jim newman costa grazos who was ceo of
nasa shipping
uh and a guy named jerry ormand who is
my mentor in the oil business
and so but uh over time uh
i i learned by storing around
uh meaning uh people will
allow information to resonate into their
subconscious
when they hear it in a story form uh and
so
when i saw that my mentors use stories
and they were pulling stuff from 20 30
years ago
that resonated with me and so then i
developed my storytelling abilities
and i and i i tried to frame everything
i did
in a story and a true story
and now the the the occasionally i'll
miss a date
and somebody from uh the internet will
correct me
uh no i wasn't in 2000 2001 it was 2002.
that's fine at least i i have a backstop
yeah but i'm only off a year and i've
got a million stories so give me a break
you do yeah but uh i realize how how
much they work
and now i have stories that i can tell
about you
yes i have stories i can tell about you
know brian rose
uh i have stories about many many other
successful kids
and and that resonates even more with
the kids success leaves clues
if you know all you know if successful
if the super successful people
don't hang don't chill don't go to super
bowls and all those things
and the hard asses okay
but only 98 of the high performers in
the world
are alpha males 2 percent are alpha
males 98
are regular people because for example
elon musk
zuckerberg warren buffett all share one
attribute they're introverts decide this
our continuum
correct yeah and uh so i mean you don't
have to be an alpha male
and back in the day a hundred years ago
and doing research for one of my talks
they had obviously alpha males but they
didn't call them alpha males
they called them oak trees oak trees oak
trees
because that was considered the
straightest thing in the forest
and it didn't break down and so they
were called oak trees
and the uh but when i tell people about
zuckerberg
elon musk uh warren buffett
all being introverts because most people
are introverts
most people are pleasers what drives you
then
well when i went into coaching 25 and a
half years ago
i wanted to change what was called
personal development then
and the true financial coaching stroke
mentoring
and i didn't know what i would have to
do to do it but whatever i've done in my
life
i always want to lead i want to be first
so uh
after about four or five years i
discovered uh that i
even though i'm a good motivated
motivational speaker that's not what i
want to do i want to
teach how to create generational wealth
okay wealth that normally takes
20 to 25 years to create uh which is
the definition of a generation in three
to seven years as we were saying in the
car on the way over here
three years if you do everything
perfectly which we know nobody does it
perfectly yeah
six or seven years uh for the for
somebody that's good
and eight to ten years if you're a real
doofus
and i realized the work that it would
take and that
i sold all my portfolio i sold all my
assets sally and i have been in
cash for a long long time because i
don't want there to be a conflict
between me giving the kid advice
and my own personal investment strategy
and so
the as we've continued to develop the
templates the processes the systems and
the procedures
they're based on success one success
after another success
uh last four or five years we've
produced teenage multi-millionaires
some of the teenage multi-millionaires
as you can
witness on youtube are flying around
their own goddamn jet planes now
uh we've we've produced uh the the
largest deal
in recorded history the 500 billion
dollar uh
neon which is the uh uh city of the uh
22nd or 23rd century with a mentee klaus
kleinfeld
so we've got everything from bill
millions tens of millions
hundreds of millions billions tens of
billions and even hundreds of billions
now
and we have all the systems uh how to do
it
and 99.9 of all the kids that have
benefited from qla
i've never met i would know them if they
were standing in this room
uh because we decided almost 10 years
ago to give all the product away free
because i went as he pointed out i went
from the most expensive product
online yeah to free yes because that
takes away
almost all the excuses of the kids that
are just flapping their mouth
difference between a victim and victory
is action most of you and most of the
people on the uh
youtube have led uh quite lives of
desperation
and um they live their lives as victims
just as your parents have and just
because your parents are a doctor or a
lawyer or
it doesn't make a you know that's an
honorable profession i'm not discounted
i mean being a school teacher is an
honorable profession
being a plumber is an honorable
profession you wanna you wanna
create generational wealth change the
lives of a billion people
none of your ideas in this room are
changing the lives of a million people
let alone a billion zuckerberg is the
most classic
recent example of that and god knows
he's changed the lives of three and a
half billion
i'm not so sure for the best but that's
a whole other story but i mean
you know if you're not first you've got
to be different your ideas
what's your unique selling proposition
what's your barrier to entry
all these things that you know when i
look at your your deals and
i'm not even counting the deals these on
youtube send me i'm [ __ ] forget about
that
but i mean you has anybody ever thought
this
through and the courses and the podcasts
and the webinar
doesn't anybody ever talk about barrie
to entry
if you're not first you got to be
different does anybody talk about that
doesn't register that you can make 10
million dollars in a day
i remember the first day i made 10 000
october the 5th 1974. i remember the
first day
i made a hundred thousand dollars
1976. i remember the first day i made a
million dollar that's to me
okay i remember the first day i made 10
million dollars
and i remember like when i took a [ __ ]
this morning and brushed my teeth
the day i made 100 million pounds in one
day me
without question your goals are too low
and they're too low why
mommy and daddy who probably had no
goals
you know my dad my parents only had one
goal in life
to keep me alive until i reach the age
of reason
that's it there wasn't any because i was
a
this they used to call a problem child
back in those days i don't you know but
i was
a terror to say the least how did i
become an entrepreneur
well i'm a young second lieutenant
and um i go to the old club i know they
don't have office clubs anymore but
in those days they did i'm going to the
old club and everybody's drinking
and i said why are we all drinking he
says dave inherited 1 million 400
thousand dollars
i've never heard that before i didn't
know how many zeros was in a million i'm
not buying
so i said could you write one million
forty thousand on an acting for me you
did
i said well let's drink up right so
event
a few weeks later i get an award and i'm
getting the award there
that's two star general woodward retired
three star general
west point guy and he said uh i got an
award for i came up with an idea to save
the army
two million dollars by accident that
came up
they gave me a fifty dollar war bomb
this is happening
today fifty dollar war bond if i kept it
thirty years it was fifty bucks
it was six dollars and seventy five
cents when they gave it to me
i saved them two million dollars they
gave me six dollars and seventy five
cents
okay you give me the award
royale barry you like reporting to
directors one star general another west
point kid
so we're in the open general attires on
the side of the general bonds and
deciding
i'm a first lieutenant by this time and
they said danny you ought to buy us
drinks
why is that well first of all if you
start here i'm telling you a first
contender you just start fine
you're an ass right and so i said uh but
why is that
you won that that award and i said well
sorry about 6.75
general and then he said the magic words
danny
a young boy like you in the civilian
world would be rich
and a lightbulb went off in my head
i can still remember the moment a light
bulb
i was in to be a regular army officer i
liked the military
i loved it i love the discipline i love
it you could beat it
out of people i love the trigger time
there was nothing about the army i hate
it i already loved it
but when that light bulb went up over my
head
money civilian life i was out of the
army in six months
six months and one week later i'm out
to stop a lot of people from a five
percenter
young hard charger you probably got some
of the guys
the young hard chargers the young junior
officers here uh at the naval academy
so i'm out in six months in one week
they will tell you as soon as we got
tougher as soon as we got less
pc as soon as we got
that we didn't care what they said or
thought about us we got more successful
and we started doing deals
we started doing deals you cannot do you
know
try a lot of transactions without
hurting feelings you know the old saying
about
um to make an omelette you got to break
eggs you know and
everybody that's ever had an ominous
there's normally some kind of eggshell
in it because they can't get all the
eggshell out
collateral damage fred smith the founder
of um
um federal express said and he's similar
background similar age he was a
young marine officer i was an army
officer he said when he came back from
vietnam
as soon as he realized his mistakes the
collateral damage of his mistakes
did not end up with body bags meaning
dead people he says the rest was easy
so the worst i was ever going to do is
hurt somebody's feelings make him cry
and he built federal express and he's
one of the icons of business who's still
running the business programming uh your
yourself
and your habits really isn't that
difficult when you
understand what makes the synapses fire
that's not it's not that hard but you're
not used to saying no
you're used to saying yes or not saying
anything and giving tacit approval
how many times for those of you that
have a significant other does your
significant other say something you know
just did you just give in
make peace why make war right
i don't fall into that category uh
and if you're used to saying yes
just to not make war or you're used to
giving tacit approval just not to make
more at home
that follows you in the rest of your
life
and follow suing the rest of your life
and
um but once you get used to it
like most spouses significant others
will say god he's changed she's changed
most will stay for the worse until
you get track for him till you get
momentum
oh god i like the new roles
i know i like to do this i like flying
first class
uh and that dan's a genius now
but that takes some time now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your plan of action that
you're going to execute this week
to make some immediate momentum happen
when you just get
motivated and watch a video you have a
35
chance of following through that's what
the science says but
when you write down what time what day
what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down in the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you
in theory we should be able to kill off
the russians easy but we won't kill off
the resume because they're tough
they're tough now when i went through
ranger school
they hung us from trees and put battery
wires on our testicles
there are dozens and hundreds of
lawsuits against the federal government
because the guys couldn't have kids
they'd stake us out on ant hills and
pour honey over us
and let the ants eat us for two or three
days this was the training
and now and you're right i mean uh when
uh the the spirit of the bayonet used to
be the kill
and you're you're going through a boot
camp you know many a broken tooth
cracked jaw because your drill sergeant
hits you in the face with the butt of
the rifle
and now you wonder why we're all
that's why i bring my own security
all right okay i haven't i'm not
ignoring you and a toronto if somebody
finally asked me
why did you bring the cricket bat
snowflake i said because they your
school told me i should have security
which they did i'm not going to pay a
bunch of goons no i can do the same as
they can
and i said and what and then somebody
asked me about 20 minutes
well what do you do with a cricket bat i
swear to you
and then i jumped down off the stage and
i said
because the first five or six of you
aren't going to come at me even though
there's 400 of you
because you don't want to be the first
one two or three that i knocked their
head off
but they had to ask me what i was going
to do with a
cricket bat that's that that's where we
are
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free
check out my training right here below
or if you want two hours of eric thomas
motivation check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them continue to believe
and i'll see you there